alright so what if I told you you can
actually use airdrop one of those
special Apple ecosystem features on
Android so I first saw this from
Michelle Roman on Twitter but basically
there's an Android app called warp share
that literally uses the airdrop protocol
to send files directly from an Android
phone to a Mac so I have to do is open
up the app have your airdrop on the Mac
set to everyone and then select the file
you want to share and boom the computer
sees it as a real airdrop now this app
isn't actually on the Play Store you'd
have to either side load it or compile
it yourself but if you want something a
little easier there's actually another
one that you install on the Mac it's
called near drop so this one works
basically the exact opposite way of warp
share with this you install the app on
the Mac which gives it nearby share
capabilities so now any Android phone
with the ability to share to nearby
share will see your Mac as an option
boom basically the same thing obviously
these will only work from an Android
phone to a Mac not the other way around
that's still restricted by something
called Apple wireless direct link but
hey if you want to share stuff on an
Android phone to a Mac you don't need an
iPhone